جورجيا في واجهه الاحداث مجددا وهذه المره
بسبب مشروع قانون العملاء الاجانب المثير
للجدل القانون الذي طرح في البرلمان
الجورجي اشعل تظاهرات حاشده في البلاد
خصوصا وان المتظاهرين يجدون فيه ابعادا
لهم عن اوروبا
ليسحب البرلمان القرار بعد ضغوط شعبيه
ودوليه الاضطرابات والتظاهرات دفعت كثيرين
لطرح سؤال مقلق هل ستكون جورجيا اوكرانيا
المقبله هذا السؤال لا يخص الجرجيين فحسب
المهم ايضا للسياح العرب ربما بعد تحول
هذا البلد الجميل الى وجهه سياحيه مفضله
لهم لنعد قليلا الى السياحه في جورجيا مع
هذه المهمه السابقه لليث بازاري
بين جبال القوقاز الكبرى والبحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
بلد الاديره القديمه في المناطق الثلجيه
والقرى الخلابه والطبيعه المبهره
[موسيقى]
الى جورجيا حيث الحمامات المعدنيه
والاطباق الاشهر في منطقه القوا قائد
[موسيقى]
كل حسا نتعرف معكم على هذا القانون الغريب
الذي طرح فيه جوجل وتسبب الاحتجاجات قانون
العملاء الاجانب الذي يقول كل مؤسسه غير
حكوميه او حتى مثلا وسيله اعلان تتلقى
تمويلها من الخارج بنسبه تقريبا عشرين في
المئه هي ملزمه بالتسجيل على ان شركه
عملاء اجانب هذا الطرح وضع الجمعيات
الاهليه للسيام الحقوقيه منها والاعلاميه
تحت تهديد القمع هو قانون يشبه تشريع روسي
يستخدم للحد من حريات الصحافه المستقله
ومنظمات حقوق الانسان
المحتاجون يجدون ايضا انا مثل هكذا قانون
مثلا هو يهدف اكثر الى ابعاد بلادهم على
اوروبا الغربيه وتقريبهم اكثر من روسيا
الاتحاديه ومعسكرها وهذا ما يرفضه
الجورجيون منذ ثوره الورود 2003 القانون
طرحه حزب الفيلم الجورجي وهو حزب راسه
ملياردير يعد مقربا من روسيا
على كل حال دائما في اخبار مستجده فيما
يتعلق بالتطورات الجورجيه مؤخرا
والاحتجاجات ظهرت في الشوارع الى راويه
جورجيا لا والله
طبعا بسمع انه قد ما هي جميله والطبيعه
فيها والجبال جميله جدا ان شاء الله قريبا